14 years ago I was at having a tough
time in a job I was in I was working
with a coach who helped me um work
through the notion that reaction is a
choice and uh it became such a powerful
theme for me that I I wrote it out and
stuck it on a on a bit of paper
underneath my monitor at home um with a
photograph of my family under it because
uh in that process I learned about this
Greek philosophy called stoicism the
stoics and stoics are often
misunderstood or misled labed as being
stone-faced and without Joy stoicism for
me um at its core is just a form of
discipline over oneself it's to put it
very simply it's the application of um
of your mind and the time you spend uh
to what you can control versus being
distracted by or frustrated by what you
can't control welcome to 20-minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makea wish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
[Music]
ctec
Dave mcy welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me I I
know you're so busy and I appreciate
your time thank you for being here with
me how are you thank you Mario I'm
terrific it's an honor to be here thank
you no no no the the honor is mine um
obviously um the things you've done are
are incredible way too many things to
talk about that we're not going to get
to in 20 minutes but I'm particularly
fascinated by your your perception of
leadership uh today you're the chief
commercial officer of HP a tight a small
company um I probably one or two people
may have heard about it somewhere but um
I think that looking at the long game
and looking at the way that you're
thinking about well-being in the
workplace and how do we create and we
bring our ourselves to fruitful creation
on the long term I think that's that's
topic that's personally fascinating for
me and and I know it's something that's
of personal interest for you too so
thank you again for being here tell me a
little bit about what you really really
care about you know what is sort of top
of mind for you what I think um if I
just stay with the leadership theme that
you started on because I care about many
things and as you said we don't have
enough time to cover them all um in
leadership I think there are three
responsibilities any of us have the
first is in a role like mine I'm in
sales uh hit the number right deliver
what you said you would deliver that's
important it's sort of the ticket to the
dance the second is develop the team
every leader I've ever ever met is a
leader because other people helped them
Advance develop experiment fail and I
think that's a responsibility we all
have and the third is to transform that
which you lead it's rare to find
something that when you inherit it is
perfect and that you should just
maintain there is always a
transformational responsibility we have
and so any leadership job I've had and
the one I have now these are the three
things that I focus on then we can get
to some of the principles before we got
on here we were talking a little bit
about uh Greek philosophy but yes I mean
those are the three things I think most
about in any leadership role we're
diving right in tell me about Greek
philosophy I uh I I was about 15 or 14
years ago I was at having a tough time
in a job I was in I was working with a
coach who helped me um work through the
notion that reaction is a choice and uh
it became such a powerful theme for me
that I I wrote it out and stuck it on a
on a bit of paper underneath my monitor
at home um with a photograph of my
family under it because uh in that
process I learned about this Greek
philosophy called stoicism the stoics
and stoics are often misunderstood or
mislabeled as being stone-faced and
without Joy stoicism for me um at its
core is just a form of discipline over
oneself to put it very simply it's the
application of um of your mind and the
time you spend uh to what you can
control versus being distracted by or
frustrated by what you control and I
find a lot of people get wrapped around
the axle on the things they can't
control you know my boss doesn't
understand this or the market conditions
are such and I think that that those are
things you can't control and to the
extent that you let them distract you
they take you off course from the large
list of things that you can control and
then the last thing is uh and I'm I'm
grossly oversimplifying stoicism but the
last part of it is to find joy in the
things that you have to find Joy where
you are if you have have uh if you have
health of any sort whether you're the
healthiest person in the world or you're
you're barely alive you're alive so find
joy in that if you're able to enjoy the
time of a family or friends find joy in
that if you've got a job that's
challenging for you and that financially
rewards you find joy in that rather than
always be looking to the next thing and
declaring that that's when I'll be happy
I think a lot of people spend their life
wishing for the next thing and not
finding the joy in the place that they
are and so how so that this this
beautiful mindset in accordance with the
you're you're sitting in pet right now
right the the heart of of of sort of
this the the the race to the EV of of
super Evolution and and and we feel it I
feel it in the day-to-day how does that
balance with what you're seeing you know
in in our day-to-day lives when we're
sitting in places where we feel like we
have to move fast and we have to have
sort of this this pepper constantly
driving us forward how how do we balance
this mindset yeah I mean I'll give you
an example of a person that you know
history remembers pretty well Marcus
Aurelius was a famous stoic not a person
renowned for St resting on his Laurels
right this is not something that
prevents ambition aspiration
experimentation Pursuit this is simply a
reminder of how and where to focus your
time and energy while doing whatever it
is you do and it's not that you must be
as aspirational or ambitious as those in
Silicon Valley or you know Roman EMP as
of old were but if you are that you're
able to balance that against these
principles I described so I don't see
them as anything other than compliment
in fact if anything the ability to keep
it in perspective allows you to take
more risk because you don't pour your
whole Emotional Self into a failure you
simply pick yourself up dust yourself
off and go try again 100% okay so the
the and I like the distinction that it's
not it's complimentary it's not it's not
on one against each other right
in looking from your position of
leadership you mentioned a few things
you mentioned hitting the art number
sales developing the team and
transformational responsibility yep tell
tell me a little bit about more about
transformational responsibility it's a
it's a powerful term it's a powerful
responsibility what does that
mean well I mean again to to simplify
leaving a job better than you found it
is a is a simple Benchmark I have um in
the in the company that that uh that I
lead the sales function the commercial
business for HP for us that means
ensuring that our our teams our sales
teams and all of those teams that
support the sales teams are able to sell
what customers so desperately need
rather than sell the products that might
be on the you know on the spec sheet
we're going through right now I'll give
you a good example we're going through a
perhaps a once- in a generation
transformation of how people work maybe
more maybe less frequent than once in a
generation maybe I think even less
frequent and uh and our company is well
placed to serve that we have the right
technology we have the right Solutions
we recently acquired poly which does
collaboration equipment collaboration is
at the heart of hybrid and our sales
organization needs to be capable of
conveying the value and the opportunity
for customers to take advantage of these
new capabilities and a Better Together
story and if we don't transform if we
don't change from serving customers what
they wanted to serving customers what
they now need then at our at at the
least we will lose and at the most we
will not help all these customers make
the transition to this you know this
different way of working so that's just
one but there are perhaps another dozen
areas where we have an opportunity to
transform where I will you Endeavor to
leave this role better than I found it
whenever I'm done uh but I think every
leader has can look at the team they
lead and ask that question what is not
being done today the way I I Envision it
or that we must do it and how am I going
to drive that change alongside
developing my people which may be in
service of that third goal and alongside
delivering the now right hitting the
number right I I I like the I like the
distinctions of these three elements so
looking at the transferential
responsibilities and part of that it
sounds to me like what you're saying is
setting the vision so setting where
where we're headed developing the team
to get there hitting the now goals to
know that we're hitting the Milestones
together hey tell me a little bit about
your setting the vision setting the
long-term goals what how how we you know
the balancing in your perspective of the
Here and Now versus the long-term
perspective who should be concerned with
this long-term perspective what how do
we engage with this long-term goal in
our day-to-day lives I'm thinking for
myself as an early stage CEO how am I
translating for myself from my team for
my employees how does that matter so
this will this is going to be an
impactful conversation for
me well I'll start in the middle of
where you went who who should care about
it everybody should care about it any
leader at any level in a company whether
it's a company the size of yours or the
company the size of mine every leader
should care about it because if you
don't if you leave it to others then the
risk is that you will not be an active
practitioner and that your thoughts will
not be captured in the journey to get to
what is best I find particularly in a
large company like HP that the people
who have the best ideas about how we can
change are not always sitting in head
office yeah sometimes the best ideas
come from the field or from our
customers often from our customers and
so I want everyone in the company to
feel a a connection to and a
responsibility for that transformation
firstly for the reason I said because
good ideas come from everywhere secondly
because if if this is someone else's
Journey or someone else's vision and you
don't share it it's too easy to step
away from it it's too easy to say I've
got too much right that first objective
hit the number that's more important
I'll do that and I know a lot through my
career I've known a lot of people who
who just they hit the number that's it
and it's not bad it's just that
eventually hitting the number isn't
enough and so I think that you've got to
personally commit as a leader at any
level whether you're a firstline manager
with 10 people or an executive with
thousands you've got to be in you know
in the boat as far as how it's arrived
at um what the process is a lot of what
um what we're going through right now
has has come upon us pretty rapidly if
you think back to 2019 we didn't imagine
a world like hybrid like the pandemic
and we didn't imagine most of us at
least the impact generative AI or Ai and
specifically where geni is headed will
have and so I the second part is you've
got to be um I guess healthily paranoid
about the State of Affairs because
assuming that it will be the way it has
been forever and that you you know if
you can just improve against the current
state you'll be okay I think that's um
risky so being open to and keeping your
radar out for uh these seismic shifts
really important and being and being um
I said paranoid but maybe humble so
right word acknowledging that you are
going to constantly have to reframe and
and learn as these things occur um is an
important skill that I you know I
appreciate in leaders that I look for in
leaders and I'll take uh I'll take
curiosity over certainty any day of the
week when it comes to how to come up
with uh what the vision ought to be and
what the trends we need to go and deal
with
are how do you how do you suggest a a a
person let's say in my position right
managing a team of say 15 people in
highly certain conditions the market is
constantly changing I think the world
that we're entering is going to be one
that certainty is is term maybe for a
different Century yeah and how do I keep
myself in check for
practicing these know fundamental
leadership aspects and particularly you
know the ones that we've been speaking
about what what are things that I could
do in my position or any leader in my
organization or others that would that
want to take lead leip roles how do what
what can I actively do keep myself in
check y whether I'm practicing them
properly so I have three um three
actions that I I uh practice for that
purpose the first is I read I know that
seems obvious but the more you read the
more ideas you're exposed to uh and
everything from books that were written
thousands of years ago to articles were
were written yesterday and I think
there's an awful lot of content out
there that is um that is helpful and the
ability to curate it is increasing and
so you know it's not like you're dropped
in the middle of a library you got to go
find it right you can get the content
you need so number one read number two
um the network of people you know
there's that expression that you are a
reflection of The Five People You spend
most time with I I have been influenced
through my life and career by a small
handful of people um not all of them
unfortunately not all of them are still
alive but those who are I I spend a lot
of energy uh staying connected so I can
be influ by them either because they
challenge me or because they inspire me
or both and the more time I spend with
them the more I'm able to stay true to
what we just talked about and the third
which is pretty mundane is
calendar you know where you spend your
time is who you become and so if you let
your calendar run you if in a job like
mine and I'm sure yours if I just let
the calendar run itself it would fill
with urgent some important many not
important things it would not
necessarily have the right balance of
what we just talked about and so I'm
quite deliberate about what does and
does not make it into my schedule so
that I can allocate the time to what we
just talked about I love it tell me a
little bit about what do you really care
about you know if you look at the world
today what do you really really care
about well I mean personally putting my
my work responsibilities to the side I'm
uh I'm a father of three daughters and
uh one of those they're all in their
late teens or very early 20s um one of
my daughters um is special needs and so
I have a a passion for and a connection
to that community and I will forever
have that and I care deeply about her
life in this world and the life of those
in her community
um and it has it has enriched my life
and my families and my wies and my
daughter's Liv simply having her in our
family she is an incredible human uh and
I care very much about that
um I care that that those in power
including people like you and I who have
power over organizations or products we
might develop or services that they take
it seriously I mean I I'm privileged to
be in um in a leadership role in a large
company with significant um assets our
company has assets that we can deploy in
a direction of our choosing um I think
that's an incredibly important
responsibility for leaders to take it's
not just I did my job I hit the number I
I it's I used the assets of my
organization to the benefit of a
community or the planet or a group uh
that I you know that I and we care about
and I think that deploying the assets of
the deploying the assets at your
disposal whe whether it's the intellect
you were born with or the company that
you lead and everything in between I
think we need to go beyond just you know
how much can I get from this do you feel
a do you feel a responsibility there
absolutely yes and and I think that um
and HP has a I was going to say a good
but that's too humble it has a great
track record I mean our company is 8
four years old and founded by two
leaders whose name are are on the
building who changed the way companies
thought who who pushed for corporate
responsibility before the term existed
who um who felt a community connection
was not just a convenient way of hiring
but was an integral part of a
contribution of a company to the places
that it was present so yes and and I you
know in when I do these sort things my
uh my my pedigree often comes up my dad
was at HP and so I grew up learning
about the HPA when I yeah when I was a
kid and so I had a strong connection to
the responsibility our company has taken
and continues to take for you know the
communities that we are a part of so yes
very much our company has that
responsibility it's in our DNA whatever
products and services we sell and then
finally what do I care about at work
is uh is how are we going to make life
and work better through the technology
and services that we offer we are and
I'm sure every company feels this way
but we are unique there is no company
that can provide collaboration
capability the way we can there are
companies that have a software
capability there companies that have a
hardware capability there are software
companies that have a a a solution
capability none of them have all of them
right we bought Polly last year so that
we could offer collaboration
capabilities and uh and one of the
things that I'm most invigorated by is
not everybody even agrees that this is a
need I spoke to a very senior uh leader
uh in the international World about two
weeks ago and I asked this person about
hybrid and they said no hybrid we're
back at work the pandemic behind us
we're back at work and then he proceeded
to describe his day which started at
5:00 in the morning on a call on Zoom to
another country and then ended in the
evening with another call and in between
he had meetings on Zoom meetings in like
he was describing hybrid while he was
telling me it wasn't really a thing
anymore right I I think the opportunity
for us to make hybrid or or the balance
of where we work and how we are
productive an equitable and an invisible
experience that's inspiring to me right
that ecosystem that should sit behind
making this invisible that you don't
even know you are in the hybrid world
because it's so good and so seamless
that's inspiring to be a part of yeah
well Dave I have to say that I've been
very inspired by these 20 short minutes
I I keep H reflecting at how 20 short
minutes can be can be so
meaningful and taking an attempt to step
away and and and you mention one of the
ways that you keep your mind open and to
new ideas is through Reading well one of
my ways is to speak to people like you
and to get and to get your perspective
and I have to say that I'm leaving this
conversation inspired to be a better
leader I'm inspired to be a better
transformational leader and and I'm
going back to that original s and a
sentence he said right at the beginning
that you keep I believe in a posted note
under your monitor reaction is a choice
there it is and I and I may and I may
borrow it from time to time and I may
write it down for myself uh and I have
uh and I and I so I really appreciate
your time thank you so much thank you
for the great um know work that you're
doing in a great company and thank you
for the time that you spent with me my
pleasure always uh wonderful to talk
through these things with with the
kindred spirit thanks for the time I
appreciate thank you very much
[Music]
Dave